Traduttore: Giulia Claudi
Revisore: Anisa Fezga
(Applausi)
Buondì.
Allora, cercate di mettervi
nei miei panni.
Uno viene al TED, è tutto contento,
poi ti mettono a parlare
dopo il Coscia e il Trovesi,
cioè, diciamo, una sfiga pazzesca.
(Risate)
Quindi, preparatevi al peggio.
Allora, la prendo bene perché,
come potete vedere,
io sono un inguaribile ottimista.
Uso questa slide da ormai sei anni,
da quando si è cominciato
a parlare di crisi,
-bicchieri mezzi pieni, mezzi etc...
Ci siamo parodiati
una famosa campagna dell'Economist
e mi sono buttato con questa cosa,
anche perché io faccio un mestiere
molto strano, molto complicato,
se non sei ottimista, sei morto
perché tecnicamente io da 30 anni
vi interrompo i film
più recentemente vi interrompo
i giornali online,
piuttosto che i vostri telefonini
io sono un autore pubblicitario,
un rompiscatole,
come dire, come primo approccio.
Addirittura non solo un rompiscatole,
ma esistono delle ricerche che dicono
che dopo i politici e i giornalisti,
noi veniamo giudicati
i più grandi contapalle,
quindi bisogna avere molto ottimismo
per fare questo mestiere.
In realtà io non penso che sia così,
io penso che questo mestiere,
che, ripeto, faccio da troppo tempo,
in questo paese in particolare
sia un mestiere importante,
perché noi facciamo
un mestiere delicatissimo,
noi facciamo cultura popolare,
lavoriamo, quindi...
questa è la TAC del mio cervello,
che corrisponde a quello di Homer,
però è richiesta
anche un po' di intelligenza
perché noi facciamo cose
che ottengono degli effetti collettivi
Diciamo che c'è un grande, Bill Bernbach,
che è un grandissimo pubblicitario
che ha operato tra la fine
degli anni '50 e il 1960,
forse il padre
di tutti i grandi copywriter,
cioè di quelli che scrivono
per la pubblicità,
che diceva che chi opera nei mass media,
dà forma alla società,
può portarla in alto,
oppure può scaraventarla nel fango.
Partendo da questo, io in generale,
anche quando mi occupavo
di mozzarelle o telefonini,
ho sempre cercato di pensare
al pubblico finale,
pensare che era mia madre, mio padre,
i miei amici, il mio paese,
quindi cercavo di fare delle cose
che non facessero dei danni.
In realtà adesso sta succedendo
una cosa drammatica:
non abbiamo più nulla in cui credere,
è un momento
di grandissima crisi istituzionale,
non crediamo più nei partiti,
nelle istituzioni,
nella famiglia in molti casi,
nella scuola,
perfino le rock star e i calciatori
che una volta erano punti di riferimento,
almeno per la mia generazione,
pure loro non è che sono
dei punti di riferimento.
Forse negli ultimi tempi c'è questo papa
che è interessante
e che stiamo seguendo
con grande attenzione,
non abbiamo più nulla in cui credere
ma la gente ha una certezza,
che la pubblicità fa male alla gente,
questo periodo è l'anticonsumerismo,
la pubblicità non va bene,
io invece sono convinto
che la pubblicità serva,
la pubblicità può dare una mano a un paese
soprattutto in un momento di crisi,
la pubblicità con molti colleghi
la vediamo in questa maniera
come una creatività di un albero
che fa foglie e poi fiori e poi frutti
ma soprattutto è uno strumento,
è utile, lo puoi impugnare
e lo puoi usare senza grandi problemi.
Ora cosa succede, che da un po' di tempo
stiamo lavorando su questo concetto
di "advertising civile",
cioè qualcosa che nasca dal basso,
che non sia solo commerciale,
che non sia solo vendita,
ma che abbia una vera utilità,
che serva a un paese.
Servono nuovi modelli,
quindi non serve più
-io ho parlato di interruzioni dei film,
l'interruption marketing,
come lo chiamano gli americani,
non serve solo interrompere,
entrare in casa vostra come gli scarafaggi
e proporvi di compare un giornale
piuttosto che una lavatrice,
serve qualcosa di nuovo,
serve creare un rapporto diverso.
Oggi vi porto tre esempi
di questo rapporto diverso
in cui le aziende non vendono
soltanto qualcosa,
ma cercano di usare i loro soldi
per aiutare la gente,
per esempio oggi
vi voglio parlare di mafie.
Voi non lo sapete,
ma al di là degli arresti eccellenti
e dei sequestri eccellenti,
30 miliardi di beni sequestrati
alla mafia negli ultimi anni,
case, appartamenti,
ville, aziende, terreni,
quasi tutti stanno andando in malora,
perché chi ha fatto i sequestri
poi non riutilizza
pensate che 30 miliardi
sono dieci manovre sull'IMU
voglio dire, non sarebbe neanche male
che fossero usati meglio
ecco, pensate che addirittura,
oltre a non avere una cultura
della legalità in questo paese,
clamorosamente si sta parlando
di evasione della sopravvivenza,
dura in un paese di parlare
di evasione di sopravvivenza,
pensate a Peppino Impastato,
non so quanti di voi lo conoscono,
non vi chiedo di alzare le mani,
ma so che non tanti lo conoscono
è stato ucciso 35 anni fa da suo zio,
Tano Badalamenti,
perché lui era un giornalista, un poeta
e combatteva la mafia
anche se era suo zio.
Questa persona è morta 35 anni fa,
da una decina di anni non se ne parla più
e noi abbiamo fatto
un'operazione un po' strana
abbiamo preso un'azienda
di giovani trentenni che produce occhiali
per cui già facevamo degli annunci
un po' buffi, aggressivi.
Questo ad esempio è uscito
il primo marzo dell'anno scorso
mentre Ratzinger andava in pensione,
noi lo vedevamo come un Bruce Springsteen
che non va in pensione
ma se ne va a suonare con gli amici,
piuttosto che immagini
di capovolgimento del ruolo sociale
in questo caso lui
che passa l'aspirapolvere,
quindi un'azienda che già faceva
delle cose un po' strane,
un po' particolari,
ecco a loro abbiamo proposto
di fare questo spot istituzionale
non di vendita, su Peppino Impastato.
(Video) Attore: Se si insegnasse
la bellezza alla gente,
la si fornirebbe di un'arma
contro la paura, l'omertà.
All'esistenza di orrendi palazzi
ci si abitua,
ogni cosa pare che debba essere
così da sempre e per sempre.
Insegniamo la bellezza alla gente,
così non avremo più abitudine,
rassegnazione, ma sempre
vivi di curiosità, stupore.
Narratore: non conta quello che vedi,
ma come lo vedi.
Glassing, how do you see me?
Questo spot è andato in onda su MTV
dal 10/12 al 30/12 dell'anno scorso,
è stato supportato anche
da una campagna di PR
abbiamo mandato questo film
e il suo comunicato stampa
a molti giornalisti italiani,
questo per esempio
è il prestigioso domenicale del 24 ore,
uno dei pochissimi inserti
di cultura di questo paese
dove addirittura anche qui
è stata riportata la notizia.
Diciamo che siamo riusciti,
su un pubblico molto giovane,
con un investimento molto piccolo,
a creare sensibilità,
ma la cosa divertente è che poi
è scoppiato un grande caso
cioè Repubblica ha pubblicato questo pezzo
sia sulla carta che sull'it,
in cui si parlava dell'ira della famiglia
che non si era sentita consultata
per fare questo spot.
La cosa divertente è che improvvisamente
si è aperta una discussione
ancora più ampia
di quella che noi immaginavamo
siamo finiti su tutti i telegiornali,
vi faccio vedere questo pezzettino
(Video)
Giornalista: parole sulla bellezza
di Peppino Impastato,
ucciso da Cosa Nostra.
Attore: All'esistenza
di orrendi palazzi ci si abitua.
Insegniamo la bellezza alla gente.
Giornalista: La famiglia non ci sta,
la bellezza per Peppino
era impegno civile, non marketing.
Il fratello Giovanni chiede
il ritiro dello spot,
mentre chi lo ha pensato si difende così:
P.D.: Ci dispiace
che la famiglia Impastato
pensi che abbiamo voluto usarlo
come testimonial, noi in realtà,
come Gandhi, Mandela o J.F.K.,
abbiamo usato i suoi concetti
per diffonderli alla gente,
diffonderli agli italiani,
in un momento molto importante.
Allora, immaginate decine e decine
di telegiornali,
decine di trasmissioni
in cui vengo invitato io,
o viene invitato Giovanni Impastato,
il fratello ancora vivente,
la cosa fantastica è che ci ritroviamo
in 100 giorni a andare in televisione,
finire sui giornali, improvvisamente
si parla di Peppino Impastato,
la RAI passa in due mesi
due volte I cento passi,
erano 5 anni che non lo mandava in onda,
la cosa più meravigliosa,
per quanto ci riguarda,
è Zingaretti a San Remo,
il venerdì di San Remo,
quindi la serata da 9 milioni di ascolti,
racconta queste cose che vi faccio vedere:
(Video) Luca Zingaretti:
Sono qui per parlare di bellezza
o meglio, per parlare di quello
che un ragazzo pensava della bellezza,
il ragazzo era Peppino Impastato,
era nato a Cinisi,
(Applausi)
P.D.: Applausi a San Remo,
35 anni anni dalla morte,
mai parlato di Impastato a San Remo.
(Video) Luca Zingaretti: Cinisi,
vicino a Palermo.
Era un attivista politico,
poeta, giornalista.
La Mafia lo uccise
quando aveva 30 anni, nel 1978.
Pasquale Diaferia: non vi faccio
vedere tutto,
ma quello che vi dico è che poi,
alla fine di questi 100 giorni,
al 7 di marzo, perché ci parlavamo
con la famiglia,
ci parlavamo con Giovanni Impastato,
andiamo a fare un convegno su Peppino,
l'icona e la realtà,
che viene ripreso da tutti i giornali
e dove la famiglia Impastato
decide di usare lo spot della polemica,
come scrive Salvo Palazzolo di Repubblica,
lo fa diventare lo spot dell'antimafia,
in questo momento
la famiglia Impastato
usa questo spot con un finale diverso
come spot dell'antimafia.
Ditemi se questo non è un nuovo modello
di advertising civile,
ditemi se questo non è stato utile,
vi dico solo che tutto quello
che è stato fatto,
40 milioni di persone
sono state esposte in 100 giorni,
dopo 10 anni in cui, né le istituzioni,
né i magistrati dell'antimafia,
né i giornali, né i telegiornali
hanno mai parlato di quello
che tecnicamente è un eroe dell'antimafia,
morto per combattere suo zio.
Un altro esempio di advertising civile,
rapido, veloce.
Oggi mi sono messo la maglietta Italia,
perché parlo di questo paese
ma anche perché adoro il basket,
ho la fortuna di avere uno dei clienti,
assieme a qualcuno
che è in platea in questo momento,
Pallacanestro Varese,
che è un club importante,
uno dei 5 più importanti
d'Europa per storia,
che ha come sponsor di maglia
un'azienda farmaceutica,
di cui non faccio il nome, ovviamente,
che si occupa di farmaci equivalenti.
Ecco, con questa società sportiva
e con questa azienda farmaceutica,
abbiamo voluto affrontare
un tema fondamentale,
quello della donazione,
della cultura della donazione.
In Italia non c'è cultura della donazione,
vi faccio solo un esempio
per il midollo osseo.
Germania: 80 milioni di persone,
4 milioni di donatori.
Italia: 60 milioni di persone,
meno di 500 mila donatori.
Parliamo di trapianti?
Parliamo di donazione di organi?
2 mila trapianti all'anno,
ce ne sono 8 mila in lista d'attesa,
spesso la gente muore
perché non si trovano gli organi.
Non parliamo delle sacche di sangue.
Perché vi sto parlando di questo,
perché assieme a Pallacanestro Varese
e al suo sponsor di maglia,
lanciamo un'operazione gratuita,
pagata dal cliente, società sportiva,
che è una vera istituzione,
non i medici, non il ministero
della sanità, non le SL,
una società sportiva
ed un'azienda farmaceutica,
lanciano questa campagna dove la parte
della passione sportiva del cuore
si mescola con questo key visual
nel cervello della coscienza civile
e lanciamo una grande campagna,
"tifoso immortale",
in cui chiediamo alla gente,
5 mila persone di media
al palazzetto a Varese,
decina di migliaia di persone
che praticano sport,
centinaia di giornalisti
che in provincia di Varese,
non un fatto nazionale,
lanciano questa operazione
in 3 settimane facciamo più tessere,
quindi più donatori
che in tutto l'anno
tutte e tre le associazioni.
Scusate, questo è advertising civile,
la pubblicità che fa bene,
non è una pubblicità che fa male,
pagata da aziende,
non è che stiamo facendo cose così.
Terzo modello.
Qui stiamo parlando di nascere
dal basso letteralmente
vi sto parlando di un piccolo paese
del sud dell'Italia, Sogliano Cavour,
4 mila abitanti.
Un'assessora alle pari opportunità
di giovane età,
con un figlio disoccupato
e un altro figlio in arrivo,
senza budget, mi chiama,
mi ha conosciuto 7 anni fa esattamente
in una situazione come questa,
in un incontro pubblico,
a un convegno, e mi dice:
"Io non ho un euro, come facciamo?
Voglio fare una campagna in questo paese.
- ve lo faccio vedere, questa è la piazza
del paese,
Somigliano Cavour è un piccolo, orribile,
per noi che stiamo qua, paese del sud
abitato da questo tipo di persone,
quindi immaginate la cultura maschilista
che si manifesta in questa maniera,
non ci sono soldi.
"Come faccio -mi dice- mi dai una mano?"
2.0 io non l'ho mai vista
Mariagrazia Manco,
le suggerisco di prendere
come punto di riferimento
l'immaginario televisivo,
CSI - La scena del crimine,
e le dico -Facciamo una campagna
che costi pochissimo, che costa 100 €
per stampare
questi bellissimi nastri di scotch
con scritto "riprendiamoci
la scena del delitto"
e lei con tre amiche comincia a fare
queste operazioni di comunicazione,
qui non c'è neanche
un'azienda alle spalle,
è veramente una cosa
che ci siamo fatti da soli,
cominciano a mettere questo scotch
nei punti in cui le donne da sole
non possono andare, o appunto nei bar,
dove le donne vengono osservate
in una maniera molto particolare
piuttosto che alle fermate dei pullman,
dove dopo una certa ora non si può andare,
piuttosto che -questo è sempre il bar
visto da questa parte- al centro anziani,
piuttosto che sulle panchine
vicine alla piazza,
è così che si fa advertising civile.
(Applausi)
Questo lo dedico a Mariagrazia,
che ha avuto anche il coraggio
di prendere lo scotch
e portarlo in consiglio comunale
dove è l'unica donna.
Immaginatevi le reazioni.
La cosa fantastica di questa operazione
è che ovviamente si appiccicavano
questi posterini
dove si spiegava
perché si faceva questa cosa
e soprattutto lei è diventata
una piccola diva, senza soldi,
ha una rassegna stampa
alta così solo in Puglia
grande come l'elenco del telefono
di Milano
siamo riusciti a dimostrare
che se parte dal basso,
se c'è la voglia, il desiderio reale
di cambiare le culture,
le cose si possono fare,
perfino in questo strano paese
dove i telegiornali sono pieni
di dichiarazioni
contro la violenza sulle donne
e poi di fisico non ricordo
di aver visto niente.
Il bello di questa cosa
è che sta per diventare un'operazione
che stiamo offrendo a 100 comuni,
perché il 10 marzo siamo stati premiati
a Venezia a Immagini Amiche,
e questa operazione sta diventando
un'operazione pilota,
con poco meno di 500€, qualunque comune,
qualunque associazione femminile,
anche solo tre amiche,
possono fare questo tipo di attività,
guidate da professionisti
che danno una mano.
Allora, dove stiamo andando a finire?
Stiamo andando a finire
al "ci vuole coraggio".
Io so che in questa stanza
ci sono cittadini, imprenditori,
immagino ci sia anche qualche politico,
voglio bene a tutti,
però qui ci vuole coraggio.
Questo è un paese dove non c'è più denaro
per fare attività reali, importanti,
ma dove bisogna fare
le attività importanti
per questo invito tutti a cominciare
a pensare in una maniera diversa
non si può rinunciare ad essere creativi,
perché non si può rinunciare
ad essere umani.
Quindi, piantiamola di lamentarci
che il patto sociale non funziona,
che noi paghiamo le tasse
ma non abbiamo niente in cambio
e cominciamo a pensare, come aziende,
come cittadini, come esseri umani,
che si può fare qualcosa e soprattutto che
possiamo avere tutte le idee del mondo
possiamo avere tutte le condizioni
del mondo,
ma non conta quello che si pensa
ma conta solo quello che facciamo
e sono venuto a questo TED per dirvi
che questo è il centro della questione
che la pala con cui dobbiamo zappare
deve essere anche questa cosa
straordinaria che ci nasce da dentro
perché ripeto la maniera migliore
di prevedere il futuro è crearlo
e credo che la responsibilità di quello
che succede in questo paese
e me la metto questa maglietta
con grande orgoglio
nonostante ne parli male,
quello che succede in questo paese
lo decidiamo noi.
Grazie.
(Applausi)
Un po' banalmente
ho preso la penultima slide,
ma io ci sono molto legato
e la mia lucina su questo albero
è ripetere:
"Non conta quante idee hai,
ma quante ne riesci a realizzare"
ed è un augurio, per tutti voi.
(Applausi)